i want to talk about this movie all
right i want to talk about don't look up
spoiler alert everybody
i watch don't look up
it is a film on netflix it's the most
popular it is hilarious
it is
fairly leftist
but um the way they make fun of the
government the way they make fun of the
fbi the way they make fun of the media
it's really good it's really good i i
obviously there's like annoying leftist
things in there the way they depict
trump supporters as being really stupid
so dumb they refuse to look at the sky
which is really dumb that's the name of
the movie by the way so again spoiler
alert uh now that i've uh sufficiently
warned you about the spoilers
the point of the movie is that there's
like conservatives who are too stupid to
look at the sky to see that an asteroid
is heading their way or at least a
certain part of the movie and i'm like
okay that's really stupid yeah but what
if they're
sorry
maybe they're not wrong um
but it's not it's not there are people
drinking kool-aid but the but the movie
is actually really good so i i feel a
little bit that way uh sorry but i do
anyways uh however i look at this
reminded me that i was wearing the hat
as a nod and then you look great let me
keep it on for the whole there's a lot
of beanie cohesion i know but i was
doing it as like a cute little nod and
then like you let me know that's great i
loved it okay
sorry i've got to give you so so look at
this
if you if you pay attention if you pay
attention to the news and you watch this
movie don't look up it doesn't matter if
you're a liberal post-liberal
conservative you're going to watch this
and be like man these these these
democrat individuals these activists are
extremely oblivious to what's going on
it is in fact right now in many ways the
right who are saying look at these
problems and wake up and the left who
are too stupid to look up no they're
literally looking at they're literally
looking into their masks
they're looking into their masks i mean
it's not even it's that's what's so
amazing oh god the movie is
i absolutely enjoyed the movie did you
see the movie i haven't seen it okay you
have to see them you need
the interpretations of hillary clinton i
have a friend someone's actually in the
movie so i've got to uh okay you have to
see it but again the interpretations of
hillary clinton of an individual that
that talks like bill gates of the fbi
was right on point this is why i really
really enjoyed the movie personally
myself obviously every movie has
propaganda behind it the the people who
made this movie
but the people who made this movie said
that it was you know about global
warming but if you leave it up to your
interpretations you could interpret it
in many different ways it could be
interpreted as covid it could be
interpreted as energy policy i just left
it as an asteroid because i think that
is is what the movie was about and i
loved the kind of criticism
society and it was kind of like and it
was kind of like idiocracy where where
it pointed a lot of our ignorance right
at us and it was great and the movie
heavily criticizes the media for being
flippant and self-interested i thought
that was a show the show in question
that they go on so these two scientists
are like we're gonna go on national
television to announce a comet will
destroy the earth and it's called the
daily rip and on the table
the glass that says rip is reflected and
it says lib
like oh my they the president is hillary
clinton
it's very obviously hillary clinton they
show they they do this on purpose it
zooms in and shows her hugging bill
clinton
they did not need that scene they're
telling you it's hillary clinton that's
amazing and then that voice of that big
tech entrepreneur i mean that is exactly
he wore the sweater vest too and was
literally talking like bill gates and he
was making evil decisions that ruined
and destroyed the world
destroy the world
they'll throw them out they'll throw
them out because they know they're
already thrown out it's okay they'll
they'll make memes of them they'll toss
them out because where they're going to
run hillary clinton again it's not going
to happen so so so we know we're we're
in the uh aoc level we're in we're in
we're in a place where they can they can
do that i i'm not i'm not saying that
like exactly i'm just sort of doing my
weird projection on hollywood but um
yeah okay i
they they they wouldn't have done that
three years ago they wouldn't have done
that five years ago i guarantee you they
would i think five years ago and then i
would say leonardo dicaprio was kind of
like a dr fauci uh and then he gets
corrupted and starts banging the the the
the tv show the lady that's on the tv
and schilling who's totally soulless
yeah
yeah the people on media are all taking
xanax they're all popped up on pills
they're all alcoholics which is true
i've been saying that on this show i'm
like i met and i partied with some of
the white house press corps all of them
were alcoholics dr drug abusers
when i worked at vice and this is true
for most newsrooms you worked at there
are bottles there was a jagermeister
dispenser their bottle of booze about
boo there's bottles of booze everywhere
it is project having a good time no no
no no no no no no they're alcoholics
journalists are alcoholics
hey in all these newsrooms there is
booze everywhere i never knew this sorry
can i take a little tiny side road are
you still friends with gavin i don't
know i've never been friends with kevin
oh yeah i've never i've met he's a very
good friend of mine he's yeah i've been
always been extremely kind to me i met
him i met him one time when he licked a
guy's face and that was it i was there i
was there when he licked that guy's face
i remember getting it on video and i'm
like this is weird like this is not like
what the hell is going on guys it's like
not to like age myself or whatever but
like uh vice vice was like a really big
deal when we were growing up like it was
like a it was a thing that had a chance
to have actually been something really
important anyway i knew it was important
for a time let's just look at let's get
off sorry sorry sorry i just i had to
ask that i've never actually been able
to ask you that this is a really good
point in the context of the film to be
completely honest um i think we've made
our points about the movie but the movie
is meant to be this critique it's meant
to to mock the media and talk about
right the view i think i think it's
obvious leonardo dicaprio is a big
climate change activist and this is how
they kind of view it
but what's interesting uh just to now
segway kind of into like what happened
device is that vice was supposed to
challenge a lot of the corruption that
they that they're complaining about and
then vice decided to just jump on in
exactly and you know what that's that's
what's so disappointing when you watch
this when you grow up it's weird it's
weird growing up with that okay because
like you're like
i don't want to sound dumb but like you
can't help it where you're like you're
like oh even my thing was was corrupt
you're like oh even the thing i thought
was actually cool was corrupt like like
you know everybody's got to go through
that i guess but i didn't realize that
it would happen to all of us
when you have uh
the movie makes a lot of funny points
about a media that's that's
disinterested it's really funny there's
a scene where they're like
you know um
what's the actress's name like jennifer
lawrence she's like we're all gonna die
and then they're like whoa calm down
that seems great but
it's inauthentic that's what i mean it's
inauthentic and they criticize it you
bring up vice which is interesting we
can definitely segue into that vice
versa
was authentic yeah that vice was
originally criticized because it was a
regular dude going to afghanistan yeah
and these journalists were like you
can't just put on a safari hat and point
it poop and they're like yes you can you
know what it is it's your bar buddy
saying let me tell you a story you trust
us
now vice is just corporate shell
mongering one of the things that was
really interesting about that movie was
how leo was kind of captivated and
manipulated by the corporate media and
how he was playing along after his
sidekick was of course kicked off he was
making a lot of media appearances he
loved the image of himself he saw his
ego that's quite and i'm like that's
literally freaking dr fauci right there
from my perspective how i saw it but
again bill gates blew up the world
spoiler alert uh
yeah
hold on hold on the comet was already
coming yeah the tech billionaire just
wanted to make profit and sacrificed the
plan he stopped them from blowing up the
the what's the comet because they wanted
to mine it for raw earth minerals
corporation could make more money i mean
that would that could probably really
happen okay that's what i was going to
say is that is that that's where we are
is that it's a we could literally have
something as easily identifiable as an
existential threat than a comet
coming at the entire world and if we ask
ourselves what would actually happen it
would be who could make the most money
who could who could gain the most out of
the propaganda absolutely you could do
all this and that's and that's actually
where we live and that's that's that's
uh i got i gotta say that's that's not
entirely wrong and some people would
argue that this is exactly what what
happened with this sickness that's been
around for a while that people are
exploiting the tragedy but that's what
government has been doing for a very
long time created that whenever there's
tragedy they exploit it for their own
personal benefit and they have their
corporations you guys have to realize
remember we haven't actually had a
tragedy we haven't had a non-man-made
tragedy in a very long time okay like
that's the thing is it like the asteroid
has always been this i remember in the
90s where there was like this like a
string of asteroid movies uh that that
were very very fun right like i remember
that
and then not just that but like remember
remember there is and this is something
i was actually really weirdly fond of
when i was a kid like these sort of end
of the earth uh uh
movies that were extremely fun to watch
like even like i like the dumbest ones i
like like like 2012 and like uh uh
independence day i think weren't all
they made by the same director i mean it
was the independence day it was they all
had the same plot uh 2010 there was the
freezing one there was the earthquake
one there was yes of course they all
have the same plot but there was
something like uh okay we also had to
hit the sort of higher we would hit at
that time period the higher level of uh
um uh uh
uh what's it called uh graphic uh
graphic design graphic uh graphic
graphic uh um
what am i trying to say cgi yeah cgi cgi
had sort of hit its mark right right
before like uh you know you really went
nuts with it we're like we're where
we're at now where you've we've got like
uh you know uh star wars 10 or whatever
like like there was this period of time
where where people were actually
awed by movies again and it was this
there was this one period of of like
sort of disaster movies that uh and now
and i even at that age i really didn't
like sort of big dumb movies like i i
did but i didn't but i was like very
like i was in my little art phase like
right like i was like hanging out at the
art theater and i was like i did it up
but but i'd always go to those movies
and
there's something about it there's
something there was something
there was something really pleasing
about it i don't think we're gonna get
back to that i don't think even this
movie is going to bring us back to that
because the culture that that the world
we're in is not the same and there's two
distinct worlds right and they don't
want to come and they don't want to even
they don't even want to be on the same
spaceship here's the thing the the
spaceship let's i'm i'm doing an
imaginary movie right now like like the
spaceship that that that let's say saves
the whole america we don't even want to
be on the same spaceship we don't even
want to be on the same space the reality
is that's the the exception on the right
and the rule on the left the exception
on the right is that people on the right
consistently try to have debates and
conversations and the left just says no
haha laughs and says stupid things and i
don't i don't want to be i don't i don't
want to be on that spaceship i'm sorry i
refuse but i i will say look the right
the right has their their their negative
element for sure that's why i say it's
the exception the people who are you
know acting in bad faith and trolling
they exist on all sides but the left
it's the rule you like when you have
very high profile performances
who are unwilling to actually have
conversations they they will say things
publicly like i'll come on your show tim
and i'm like awesome i really appreciate
it we'll we'll fly you out first class
and then they go ha ha just kidding
or they go they go privately and say
first class like from if i just picked a
different city yeah just a different
thing no so like i'm i'm just trying to
kind of accentuate the point that we've
had many high profile lefting
personalities smack talking and i'm like
yo you're always welcome no they'll be
terrible they'll be terrible they'll say
yes publicly and then privately say ha
ha i was never going to come on in the
first place and then and they think
that's some kind of thing then they'll
get all of their you know followers or
whatever to start pushing the lie that
we wouldn't let them come on because
they've got to keep their people in the
matrix thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you